foreign
[Music]
concerns the World Cup it's like the
Super Bowl except the rest of the world
actually gives a [ __ ] the World Cup is a
big deal a country even qualifying for
it is a cause for huge celebration just
watch the watch this Australian reporter
lose his mind when his Nation beat Peru
on penalties to make it to the
tournament
how good is this
[Applause]
foreign
to amplify people's Joy shrieking to the
guy kissing the camera to someone
stealing his scarf which sadly he never
got back and the reason I know that is I
have it now
sure it used to be your mom's but now
it's all mine
the World Cup got underway today and
we've talked before about the
organization behind it FIFA a
cartel-like group of scumbags and
assorted criminals who occasionally put
on soccer matches feed FIFA has always
been terrible which is what makes it a
little hard to hear FIFA's current
president claim that their event isn't
just about sport it's a net positive for
Humanity
this FIFA World Cup
a tournament of peace and unity
will be the one that brings the world
together after some difficult times we
should never underestimate the unifying
power
something so unique has well that is
some pretty grandiose talk coming from
the star of what the [ __ ] are those
eyebrows Charlie Brown but the truth is
a lot more complicated than that which
is not to say that I am not excited
about the World Cup because I am it only
happens every four years and I look
forward to it the way people with leap
year birthdays look forward to leap
years with an enthusiasm somewhere
between understandable and honestly kind
of pathetic
and this world cup is being hosted for
the very first time in the Middle East
by the small nation of Qatar which is
going all out to turn it into a major
branding event even signing a massive
multi-million dollar agreement with
David Beckham to be an ambassador for
the country which presumably includes
getting him to make more videos like
this I think everyone knows how much I
love food and the food culture is very
exciting in Qatar this is what I love
you know I love to go to spice markets I
love to go to fish markets I love
American oh yeah oh yeah everybody knows
how much I love attacker but what I love
is also we are now in this amazing Place
yeah yeah using the traditional spices I
love riding I love a bike Community I
love being in the middle of nowhere and
talking and
18 and this is perfection for me
so but
I have lost the following food food
a taco bike culture and of course being
in the middle of nowhere eating and
talking they really should have just
kept taking him to places to see what
they could get him to say he loves for
money I love public bathrooms the Aromas
the atmosphere I just love them I love
cemeteries everyone knows how much I
love tombstones and grieving families I
love Proctologist offices I just love
Proctologist culture this is perfection
for me
the point is the next month is qatar's
Big Moment On The World stage they're
hosting an event expected to attract
over a million Spectators in person to a
country just the size of Connecticut but
as you may have heard underneath the fun
pageantry and David Beckham doing bad
Anthony Bourdain cosplay is a much
darker story small signs of which have
leaked out this week like in this moment
from a Danish reporter but then foreign
you invited the whole world to the you
invited the whole world to come here why
can't we film it's a public place but
you can break the camera okay you break
the camera okay
so you're threatening Us by by Smashing
the camera wow just a reminder he was
asked how would you describe working
conditions for journalists in Qatar and
just seconds later a bunch of golf cart
goons showed up to answer that question
for him although credit to this guy for
being so excited to appear on Daily News
TV and we gave the camera a little wave
before presumably smashing the [ __ ] out
of it
Russian journalist is just the tip of
the iceberg here one that includes a
host of human rights violations so given
all of that tonight let's talk about the
Qatar World Cup and let's start by going
back to the moment back in 2010 when the
winner of the bid to Hostess tournament
was announced by the former head of FIFA
sepplatter the winner
to organize
the 222 FIFA World Cup is Qatar look as
a general rule I try not to make fun of
old men who don't speak English as a
first language but due to evil
sepplatter is an exception and him
saying 222 like a vampire telling the
time will just always be funny to me but
that moment truly stunned people because
for reasons that it turns out FIFA were
fully aware of Qatar was a fundamentally
unsound choice for a summer soccer
tournament FIFA conducted its own
objective analysis of the various bids
which found that Qatar was an unsuitable
place to host the World Cup and a
dangerous place to host the World Cup
that the summer temperatures would be a
hazard to the health of the players and
the fans
that Doha simply didn't have space for
the kind of Stadium infrastructure that
was going to be required they would have
to build nine new stadiums and there
wasn't enough room for them in Doha so
they would have to kind of create a
whole new city yeah Qatar wasn't just a
surprising Choice it was logically
inexplicable it'd be like if the
Westminster dog show awarded the best in
show title to a tortoise nothing against
that tortoise but not only should it not
have won it should have been
automatically disqualified
now the first and most obvious problem
was that Qatar is notoriously scorching
hot in the summer that is why FIFA
eventually moved the World Cup to
November but qatar's initial pitch
simply pretended that heat wouldn't be
an issue promising that they built
air-conditioned outdoor stadiums while
Qatari scientists pitched ideas like a
massive remote control artificial Cloud
that they could move around to cover
stadiums in shade which a didn't exist
and B wouldn't solve your problem anyway
it's the multi-million dollar equivalent
of pulling down the little car flap to
keep the Sun out of your eyes and at
this point you will not be surprised to
learn of the many accusations that Qatar
won their World Cup bid through bribery
with allegations including that three of
the officials who agreed to vote for
Qatar did so in exchange for a million
dollars each and I won't say the guitar
definitely got the World Cup through
bribery but I won't say that they didn't
and I will say that they did and what
well they deny that there was any
misconduct in their bid the fact
remained they were going to need to
build not just a bunch of new stadiums
but also a new airport metro system
roads and about a hundred new hotels
they had to build so much new
infrastructure in fact that even the
World Cup's mascot laib doesn't seem to
be able to believe what his country has
just done
first thing I want to show you is the
stadiums oh the stadiums
it's mind-blowing Arenas designed by
some of the best architects in the world
this is the same city can you believe it
didn't exist 10 years ago
now it's one of the city's hosting FIFA
World Cup matches you know what life I
can't believe that City wasn't there 10
years ago either and it's actually a bit
alarming if you drove by an empty plot
of land with a sign reading coming soon
at TGI Fridays and the very next day
drove by and saw the grand opening of it
you've only have some questions about
how the [ __ ] it happened that fast
according to one estimate qatar's
government has spent more than 300
billion dollars on infrastructure
projects and look they can afford that
they have a lot of money thanks to their
huge oil and natural gas reserves what
they don't have a lot of though is
qataris because Qatari Nationals only
number around 380 000. however the
country has an overall population of
nearly 3 million and that is because
ninety percent of it consists of
foreigners and migrant workers and it's
migrant workers who perform most of the
manual labor there and those laborers
are the ones who've had to build all the
new infrastructure for this tournament
which brings us to one of the major
scandals underlying it guitar recruited
hundreds of thousands of workers mainly
from India Nepal and Bangladesh through
agencies in their home countries just to
secure a job migrants had little choice
but to pay recruitment fees of up to
four thousand dollars before they left
the country
and once they got to Qatar they were
already in debt and trapped in a system
known in the Middle East as kafala the
kafala system can be a form of modern
day slavery and the features of it the
mount in some cases to force labor it's
true all the new stadiums and
infrastructure were essentially built
through modern day slavery so we should
probably introduce a new collective noun
to refer to this group of stadiums a
gaggle of geese a pot of whales an
atrocity of stadiums the Kabbalah system
exists in some form in several countries
in the Middle East and under it in Qatar
workers couldn't switch jobs or leave
the country without the explicit
permission of their employer in some
cases because they might have literally
had their passport taken away and being
so fully dependent on an employer meant
that laborers had virtually no rights
take a niche a laborer from Nepal who
maintains that he was routinely
underpaid and for doing work in truly
brutal conditions
I went to Qatar in 2019 on the 21st of
March I started working at the Lucille
Stadium
it was very hot in Qatar it got up to 52
degrees Celsius the first year I was
there
I used to sweat in the exact way as if
it was raining from the sky you know how
halt
Greek Celsius is
if you build a stadium in that heat you
should get to own it that shouldn't be
Lucile stadium that should be a niche's
[ __ ] stadium and no one should be
allowed inside it without saying that
out loud and there's something pretty
[ __ ] up about arguing it's too hot for
Peak athletes to be outside for 90
minutes but you know what it's
completely fine for people to build
stadiums in that heat for hours a day
and for months on end and that's not
even getting into the living conditions
that workers there were subjected to we
drove outside the city to a place the
government doesn't want people to see
the sprawling labor camps where the
workers are housed inside the men were
packed wall to wall ate to a room the
heat was stifling the kitchen filthy the
beds they told us infested with bed bugs
22 year old coomb lives here among 150
other men
they share two bathrooms there's no
shower here there's nowhere to wash your
body
where do you wash your body then buckets
hard to believe but in these camps it's
routine
at another Camp the toilets overflowed
with sewage and two filthy kitchens were
being shared by 600 men that is
horrifying no one should ever have to
live like that just wait until laib
finds out about this
yeah yeah your tournaments built on
human suffering buddy and you should
know when that reporter went and talked
to the head of one of qatar's leading
Sports organizations it didn't go well
you go yourself uninvestigate it you
will see them living in a very you know
comfortable healthy environment
comfortable and healthy of course in a
very healthy environment alhamdulillah
with all due respect we have gone to the
camps you went yourself yes this week in
Doha where you have hundreds of
thousands of men living in labor camps
some of them packed into small rooms
eight men to a room like the one we saw
10 men sharing a toilet no showers have
you been to the the labor camps yourself
sir
I'm not gonna answer your questions
you don't want to answer that of course
I don't want to answer it and with that
we were told the interview was over
incredible nothing says workers live in
a comfortable and healthy environment
quite like leaving the room 30 seconds
after you realize that the person you're
talking to has actually seen that
environment
and it gets worse a guardian
investigation found that 6 500 migrant
workers died in Qatar from 2010 to 2020.
now that number accounts for all migrant
worker deaths in Qatar not just those
who worked on stadiums but the Qatari
government's preferred count states that
they've actually only been 37 deaths
among laborers at World Cup stadiums and
of those that only three were work
related but if that number seems
suspiciously low to you it's because it
very much is their preferred count is
conveniently limited to the small
handful of work sites that were under
the highest level of scrutiny and
exclude the hundreds of other World Cup
related projects what's more autopsies
weren't done on most of these workers
with one investigation finding that
nearly 70 percent of deaths of Indian
Nepali and Bangladeshi Nationals were
attributed simply to natural causes or
Cardiac Arrest which feels deliberately
vague because Cardiac Arrest just means
their heart stopped which is literally
how everybody dies I can tell you with
full confidence that his heart stopped
is how both I and kid's Rock will die
that doesn't mean that our Cardiac
Arrest will be caused by the same thing
though does it one of our deaths will
likely involve a lot of meth a monster
truck and a variety of illegal fireworks
and the other death will be Kid Rocks
and Qatar will argue that they have made
some significant labor reforms it's
something that the head of their World
Cup efforts has proudly bragged about
if we look at the actions that the
government has taken so far laws
implemented and being applied as well
the follow system has been dismantled
both in terms of allowing for workers to
change employers and at the same time
also there was the exit permit system
they couldn't leave where they couldn't
leave without permission that has been
dismantled as well look those reforms
sound great and to an extent they are
but they also have some major asterisks
on them workers in Qatar have said that
they are still required to get
permission from their current employer
before they can move to a new job and
have also experienced retaliation from
their employers when they try to leave
but also the reforms that he's bragging
about there only began to be implemented
in 2018 when much of the hard work was
already done so he is bragging about
dismantling the kafala system while
sitting in a Stadium built using it the
only way that pat on the back could have
been more hypocritical is if he'd forced
a migrant worker to do it for him in a
120 degree Heat
but incredibly it's not just Qatar
bragging about the progress that's been
made FIFA has had the nerve to claim
credit for it too all the changes that
have happened in this country in terms
of Human Rights and workers rights and
so on
human rights would not have happened or
certainly not at the same Speed without
the projectors of the World Cup oh
corruption Caillou that
out of a [ __ ] claim there because you
cannot possibly argue FIFA deserves
credit here FIFA's evaluation of qatar's
bid had literally zero mentions of Human
Rights or demands for labor reforms
think of it like this if the country had
made no changes to its Catholic system
in the past few years and instead had
passed a law called the doubling down on
slave labor Act of 2019 you know what
would have happened the World Cup still
would have kicked off in Qatar today
isn't that right live wink if you agree
yeah I [ __ ] knew it I knew you knew
what was going on there
when FIFA awarded Qatar the World Cup
there was only one way those stadiums
were getting built and there was only
one group of people who were going to do
it and they gave them the tournament
anyway and that is not the only
troubling thing that they had to have
known back then because let's take a
moment to talk about qatar's human
rights situation and I recognize every
country has human rights issues
including this one for more on that see
every other story this show has ever
done but Qatar is in some ways Next
Level women there have very limited
rights they need permission from their
male Guardians to marry work in many
government jobs and travel abroad until
certain ages also because sex outside of
marriage is illegal pregnant women have
to present a marriage certificate to
receive prenatal care which I hesitate
to even tell you about just in case the
Supreme Court is watching this show
tonight and getting any new ideas
as for the LGBT community sexual conduct
between men is criminalized and can
result in seven years in prison and FIFA
was not unaware of this set platter even
joked about it just days after Qatar was
awarded the tournament because when he
was asked what advice he would give to
gay fans who might want to travel to
Qatar this was his fun response then I
would say then that they should refrend
from any sexual activities
you know they say in comedy you can
either punch up punch down or co-sign
oppressive governments for a quick laugh
while looking like the penguin went to
Wharton and we all know which option he
just chose there get set platter a
Netflix special it seems like he's ready
now Qatar has frequently repeated that
everyone is welcome at this world cup
including gay fans but as this gay
Qatari man who was granted asylum in the
U.S citing the dangers he faced there
points out even if that is the case for
the next four weeks it's a hell of a
blind eye to turn
it's like having
a household
with children that are domestically
abused
and now you're gonna have a fancy dinner
party
people can can come in they can bring
their kids their kids can jump on the
table and they can do everything that
they want the children that live there
are going to be in the basement quiet
behaving
and they can jump on the table like the
other kids that visited
because they will be punished in that
household for doing it
well now you know that the children
there are abused
so how are you showing up to our home
exactly the Qatari government is
engaging in some truly horrendous
behavior and we can't just gloss over
that and uncritically put it in the
spotlight it's an authoritarian regime
not male [ __ ] Gibson by the way
here's a fun game Guess how many movies
he's been in this year you're wrong it's
seven This truly has been the year of
Mel and none of this the working
conditions the oppression of women or
gay people was a deal breaker for FIFA
in fact qatar's authoritarian Tendencies
may actually have been a deal sweetener
because FIFA's long had a soft spot for
autocrats and I'm not just saying that
because they gave the World Cup to
Russia in 2018 or went ahead with one in
Argentina in 1978 when it was run by a
military dictatorship or even that they
held the second World Cup ever in
Mussolini's Italy in 1934. they've said
it themselves FIFA's former Secretary
General Jerome Valk once said I will say
something which is crazy but less
democracy is sometimes better for
organizing a World Cup when you have a
very strong head of state that is easier
for us organizers and even for a quote
which is prefaced by I will say
something which is crazy that is [ __ ]
nuts
but authoritarians are good for FIFA and
FIFA is good for authoritarians as this
critic points out Russia's World Cup
four years ago was preceded by a lot of
controversy and criticism but that's not
what people remember about it what you
saw in the run-up to 2018 was a lot of
coverage of what was happening in Russia
a lot of coverage of the rates abuses a
lot of interest in that a lot of
Engagement in it
and I think what the Caterers will have
noticed was how that all vanished as
soon as the first whistle blew
and I think everyone became captivated
by the football
the categories know that if they can
just get to that first whistle then
they're they're over the line
it's true
to be washed away once it begins and
incidentally what a VIP box to be a part
of there quick tip for the president of
FIFA if you're gonna make arguments
about how your organization is a global
Force for good maybe try not to sit
between Muhammad bin Salman and Vladimir
Putin because you want a filling in a
real [ __ ] sandwich there and the thing
is that first whistle has now been blown
Qatar played Ecuador in the opening game
of the tournament earlier today so what
now well workers like a niche hope that
some of the athletes participating can
help shine a light on all the
exploitation that went into this event
[Music]
my message for Messi thousands of
workers like me have worked on the
stadium we did not get our salary our
benefits
I hope that if you talk about workers
like us maybe we will get what we are
owed
I do not have much Faith but still I
have hope yeah and that hope is pretty
moving especially given all the reasons
not to have any and I really hope that
Messi hears that message though given
that he plays for Paris Saint-Germain a
team literally owned by the state
investment fund of Qatar I wouldn't hold
your breath waiting for him to criticize
them people generally don't openly [ __ ]
on their employers unless of course that
employer is Warner Brothers Discovery in
which case you can happily [ __ ] away
because apparently they're too busy
canceling shows to notice and and I will
say some players to their credits have
been speaking out Harry Kane and other
team captains have said that they'll
wear a one love armband during games and
organizations from Australia's national
team to fifth Pro the international
players union have issued statements
condemning qatar's treatment of workers
women and gay people but ultimately it's
not the players who are responsible for
this mess it's FIFA they put the World
Cup in Qatar and everything that's
happened since then has been a complete
disgrace and here's the thing I'm not
saying that you shouldn't watch this
world cup or be excited about it as
tough as this is to admit I will be
watching one of my greatest Joys is
sitting completely alone in my living
room and cheering on England until
they're inevitably knocked out in the
quarterfinals on penalties but let's try
and make sure a line is drawn here
because in a few weeks time the World
Cup will be over the final whistle will
be blown on December 18th in the stadium
that a niche built in a city that didn't
exist 10 years ago and FIFA will happily
move on and while they will point to new
human rights policies that they've now
adopted we'll see how truly committed to
those they really are especially given
that one of the suitors to host the 2030
World Cup is rumored to be Saudi Arabia
which also uses the kafala system and
has an even worse human rights record
than guitar look there is no reason to
believe that FIFA will ever do the right
thing but I would love it if it could
for just once in its shitty history find
a way to hold itself to the lofty ideals
that it has the goal to profess I would
love that as much as I love the World
Cup itself and maybe just maybe even as
much as David Beckham loves a taco
because that would be Perfection for me